let me tell you the stakes were
ridiculously high for this game yes both
teams because look Chris and Peter King
made this point last week and he'll be
joining us in about 25 minutes and we'll
give him a chance to do a little victory
lap on this one the 49ers go from being
the team that we assume will be the
number one seed in the NFC to now being
a team that is going to have to fight
and scratch and claw the rest of the way
to hold on to the division title because
as it stands they have one loss Seahawks
have two if the Seahawks are within that
one game window going into week 17 when
these two teams get together again that
would be it's amazing I mean that's for
the NFC West right there's our there's
our week 17 Sunday night game it's
Giants cowboys 1993 all over again right
where the winner gets the 1 seed and the
loser has to the walk yeah right that
was in my that was the Sims family was
on the short end of the stick there and
that game went into overtime and yeah
man that still hurts me still hurts my
dad too but it was it wasn't sorry Phil
yeah sorry Phil screw Phil Simms but
either way it was yeah monumental I mean
teams like the Saints who slipped up
this weekend and you know the Packers
you slipped up last weekend all of a
sudden they're looking at it going oh
we're we're back in the thick of things
here oh wait and we got the 49ers under
schedule in a few weeks so we can even
the playing field right there and really
still have a chance to be the 1 or 2
seed I'm gonna say this ok I still think
the 49ers are the better football team
than the Seattle Seahawks I don't know
if I think it's realistic for Seattle to
be able to win the way they did last
night with all the defensive turnovers
and doing that now maybe they proved to
me down the stretch that this becomes a
consistent thing on a week to week basis
and if it does then I apologize but I
still think I would take the 49ers here
down the stretch as much as I respect
people and Russell Wilson and Bobby
Wagner and the way they play and
approach the game I still think the
49ers are the best team in the NFC maybe
not by as a big a margin as I thought
going into the game though
well and you know it's good news for the
teams that are vying for the top spot in
the NFC that the 49ers lost very good
news for the Packers in the Saints and
obviously excellent news for the
Seahawks who needed to avoid picking up
their third loss but for the teams
looking at the wild-card berth that was
a horrible outcome last night if you're
the Rams you had to be rooting for the
49ers to win that game go ahead and
concede the division to them right hope
the Seahawks fly it down yes so you can
climb back into it it was a bad outcome
for the Rams bad outcome for the Vikings
bad outcome for any other two Eagles it
is hoping to tree exactly trying to get
a wild-card berth because what we've
seen now with the Seahawks winning it
cements the Seahawks as either the five
of the sixth seed it only leaves one
spot open via wild card for whoever
finishes in second place in the NFC East
FC north and NFC South yeah that's right
I mean you know and then you know you
think about just the Vikings
Philadelphia conversation you know yeah
that that's a that's a tight one there
but the Vikings already won the
head-to-head battle so they're they got
a little tiebreaker on the Eagles you're
right I'd never even really thought
about that aspect to start the show but
that was big for the all those teams and
and yeah that makes the Rams life very
hard and certainly the Eagles Dallas NFC
East clash there that is going to come
down now to Jesus looking like it's
gonna be win the NFC soar you're gonna
be home that's really all there is to it
but man I just the NFC is still so
talented so many good teams and I just I
just can't get over the game last night
in general Mike I just it was so fun to
watch it was old school football I mean
I just felt like it was you know not a
lot of like trick plays and things like
that it was we're gonna run the football
we're gonna out hit you Pete Carroll and
Kyle Shanahan both have that mantra of
like I don't want you on the team unless
you go pedal to the metal
every play and that's what we saw out
there we saw 22 guys who are just
willing to put it on the line play after
play after play and like what Pete
Carroll said in the press conference
gonna go a long way for his team this is
a battle-tested moment that's gonna give
them a lot of confidence like their did
the Ravens to beat the Patriots where
this
to be a springboard to go okay you know
we knew we were good but now we know
we're really good like we're one of the
best teams in the NFL and let's build on
that but think about this we have talked
previously about what a battle the NFC
playoffs will be and how the team that
all money emerges may have nothing left
when it's time to face the AFC
representative the Super Bowl right
before we even get to the playoffs we're
gonna have these regular-season games
that are physical that are intense that
go down to the wire and maybe beyond as
everyone tries to position on the
playoff tree number one to get in number
two to finish as high as you possibly
can we've got more look at the look at
the schedules coming up it's a Saints in
the 49ers get together that is a huge
game as it relates to the playoff
picture the Packers in the 49ers
gigantic game we talked about Seahawks
and 49ers getting together again
the Rams still play both the 49ers in
the Seahawks again there are some
gigantic games that are coming up and
and for the teams that aren't in the
playoff mix this is that one last
opportunity to be relevant and throw a
wrench in someone's gears like the
Falcons did to the Saints on Sunday yeah
you're exactly right but I think the
aspect do you bring up you know about
the NFC in general and especially
because you look at a lot of these teams
and before the playoffs even get here
you know to your point they're gonna all
be playing each other here down the
stretch to where men the 49ers got to
end the season three out of the last
four games are at the Saints they get
Atlanta at home then they got to play
the Rams and then at Seattle again to
what you said you know the Saints the
last three games of their years they're
gonna be playing against the Colts at
Tennessee and then at Carolina Carolina
still might be fighting for a spot at
that point you know so it will be
interesting I mean can you just imagine
and the NFC Pie off some of these teams
like the one seed San Francisco 49ers
they could be sitting there going are
you kidding me we're the 1 seed
we got a bye week and we got to play the
Seattle Seahawks or somebody like that
to start the playoffs like you know
that's just it's gonna be unbelievable
TV and viewing for the NFC playoffs
because I really look at it right now
and go all
six teams could go to the Super Bowl and
win it and I would say maybe I'd give
you know Dallas the least chance there
but still they have enough talent that
you go no they have a Super Bowl roster
and if they get hot and turn it around I
wouldn't be shocked to see them make it
a run yeah we talked about this
yesterday I look at their schedule the
rest of the way look at the Eagles I
think the Cowboys may not make the
playoffs at all and you know one other
division to consider well I think we
touched on this also yesterday in the
aftermath of the Vikings Cowboys game
the Vikings the Packers the the Vikings
are only one game behind Green Bay they
lost week two at Lambeau Field they play
week 16 on a Monday night and that
division and possibly a bye may come
down to the last two weeks the Vikings
are at home both weeks
Packers Bears the Packers are on the
road both weeks at Minnesota at Detroit
and it could be that that you know the
Packers go into week 16 as the 2 seed
and they come out a week 17 as the six
seed yeah there's no doubt I mean we
could see a lot of juggling as far as
standings and where everybody is not
only in just in the NFC North but
throughout the NFC in general the last
two and three weeks of the year I just
can't get over it because stats did a
great job of kind of putting all the
schedules in front of us and it's just
gonna be so many meaningful games down
the stretch of December between really
the upper class of the NFL and that's
that's what football is all about to me
it's hard hitting tight football games
coaches got to make tough decisions
that's why I want to tune in December
type football and I think we're gonna
get it meanwhile with the 49ers losing
previously ain't no right the Saints
losing previously 7 & 1 the 49ers were
number one in the PFT Power Rankings the
Saints were number two there's gonna be
a new number one coming out later today
yeah and it's it's mm-hmm I think that I
think it's time to give the Baltimore
Ravens a little more Jackson there do I
mean number three you're gonna have your
work cut out for you this week I'm
actually really interested is interested
to see what you're gonna do as far as
your your PFT write your power rankings
because tomorrow
yeah when you just try to sort out New
England Baltimore San Francisco New
Orleans in Seattle man good luck with
that Mike I'm gonna I'm a it's a win-win
situation for me basically cuz I'm gonna
tell you you're wrong just about no
matter that's great
I can tell you right now barring some
dramatic change I'm gonna put Lamar
Jackson in the Ravens at number one
okay deserve I'm where do you and I
think right right now they are no where
do you lean for number two there that's
to be determined okay that's that's a
hot one
real or you know when you find out
sometime between noon and 1:00 Eastern
at Pro Football Talk calm we'll have the
full slight but it's gonna be a big to
such a good amazed value way to go
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports